if you walk around in this world
thinking that men hate women or are
looking to take advantage of women you
are going to miss out on some of the
greatest joys in life we are going to be
taking today this male privilege test
which I want to make sure they have this
context for you it's a it was created by
a cartoonist left-wing cartoonist
berried Deutsch and what's most
important is that since been used by the
National Organization for men against
sexism product humanity from Arizona
State University diversity and social
justice at California State University
and the University of Western Australia
along with other prominent organizations
so at one point you would think this was
a joke quiz like back in the early days
of the internet Rick is is mr. world
first name a bomb at the helm of this or
perhaps dot-com first name break like
you would think that this was a joke
this is an actual privilege test a male
privilege checklist actually that we are
all going to take together I guess these
aren't really questions either just
things that you have to check a little
check checking your proof so we'll go
through this number one my odds of being
hired for a job when competing against
female applicants are probably skewed in
my favor the more prestigious the job
the larger the odds are skewed your
thoughts half-asian bill yes they are
and that is because I'm better than you
nothing to do everyone with anything
else but against female applicants
against all applicants I Lee I am better
than the ladies and the men you're
better than about Gerald and I don't
know being a psalm I guess yeah dominate
jobs in the humanities and though there
aren't as many in the the STEM fields
they're actually twice as likely to be
hired as likely as comparably qualified
men to be hired in stem simply because
there's a push for women in these field
so that's the one area where you could
say there's a disproportionate number of
men but actually women are twice as
likely to be hired they just don't want
to do those jobs number three if I am
never promoted and I want you guys to
take this by the way this is the Barry
Deutsch will have the link
I think we have a box right now up here
with a link and a link underneath in the
description you should all take this
because this just goes to show you this
is very much notice
it's like psychics it's the BS from
psychics I'm seeing that you have around
a relative is it John
is it Jake this could apply to everyone
this is designed to make you think that
everybody out there not only applicants
not only employees but everyone doing
the hiring everyone in the legislative
Blanche Blanche branch or the
legislative bland chance depending
overrated
I prefer Naomi what's the point is
judicial legislative employees employers
this test is designed to no matter how
you answer yeah everyone is sexist yes
number three if I am never promoted it's
not because of my sex that's when it
comes to grammar that's a double
negative answer that at least two
negatives yeah so I if I am never
promoted it's not because of myself so
if I I'm not comfortable calling it on
the both check is it's not sort of
asking the questions I could this be
appropriate in this room because
sometimes there are realms we're gonna
you know what women tend to perform
better in these yeah feels have worked
whether it's watching working with
children for example women are more
trustworthy if women are less likely to
harm a child I will say this here at
this office when we have people who work
abroad we've had better luck with women
being self-starters and on the flip side
we've had better luck with men sort of
being in the pocket and high-pressure
scenarios being comfortable that being
said not all women not all men but we've
definitely had better luck with women
sort of being self leaders it's a I take
that into account it's a question of
percentages versus individuals right you
if you take the statistical summaries of
an entire populace and then you say this
defines the individual you have a
problem that's what racists do racists
say I'm gonna take this entire
stereotype down I'm gonna say it applies
to every individual regardless of their
circumstance but that's what this test
is doing it's saying I'm going to apply
this stereotype to every single employee
and employer regardless of what they
actually do right and oversimplification
yes it would be like saying because
coronavirus was part of some plot in a
bio weapons chemical facility in Beijing
I need to execute half-asian bill every
time yes the sniffles very much agreed
six if I do the same task as a woman and
if the measurement is at all subjective
chances are people will think I did a
better job
no no it's I think it's the other way
around yeah okay sometimes sometimes it
isn't but that being said particularly
in the realm of comedy so I'm talking
about I know in the realm of
entertainment there are far lower
standards for women in comedy let me
explain what I mean with this there are
some very funny woman out there Samantha
but yes there's a very funny woman out
there one of my favorite comedians ever
is Kathleen Madigan far-left
I think she's you know you would say
maybe she's really more of a Rust Belt
Democrat but she's a well-known Democrat
toward with Lewis Black I think she's
very funny that being said a lot of the
times people say well if you watch used
to be premium blend on Comedy Central
any sort of showcase comedy set they'll
say really for every eight men there are
two women or they're fun there are four
women they wanted to be 5050 hears
anything if you go to an open mic or if
you go to a city anywhere in the country
now you look at the comedy show you'll
probably see ten percent of the
comedian's entering into comedy are
women let's call it twenty five and a
high end but if it's twenty five percent
that's the total talent pool and you are
making them fifty percent of the
representatives in the comedy world
right you just like in STEM fields are
more likely to advance women in comedy
to prove that women are funny what does
that do that undercuts women who are
really actually funny out there right
why does samantha bee have a show and
someone like Kathleen Madigan doesn't is
that we're throwing throwing Lily Tomlin
Kathleen Madigan in in in and what's the
name that Michele well in the same
[Applause]
really if you're funny or not that's it
it should can you do the job that people
are asking you to do and if you can
fantastic if you can't I'm sorry go get
more training go go you know do other
shows and get funnier number seven if
I'm a teen or adult and if I can stay
out of prison my odds of being raped or
relatively low relatively food prison
why don't we include prison because it
makes numbers higher you're like well
that's not well the guys being raped in
prison aren't big fans of it ya know
vote some my email does numbers and
rapes
I didn't never thought I would be saying
that like I want you to include prison
rape I'm just saying on this test sole
reason if we specifically took it out
and got really quiet on average I'm
taught to fear walking alone
I am taught if you're walking alone
after dark an average public space is
much less than my female counterparts
are interesting you should bring that up
because men are robbed far more often
than women yeah and I think the air if
you're weaker like if you're a small guy
you have maybe a little bit higher
chance of victim in an average public
place if you're a big guy like me are
you walking we probably have a list less
of a chances because the other guy can't
kick our ass sorry if you're a female
with a gun
you're probably walking pretty confident
right number nine if I choose not to
have children my masculinity will not be
called into question I I don't feel like
that question has a sexual premise at
all or a gender-based premise at all no
that being said I will tell you when it
does a woman is unable to conceive
typically speaking women are very the
her friends are very supportive very
sympathetic yeah if a man is firing
blanks you just get mocked mercilessly
yes we don't we don't like each other a
lot true we don't no no we really don't
so I don't really know there's all that
realm here's the other question who is
it that's calling women's you know
femininity into question if they don't
want to have kids is it men well I think
it social construct yeah it's other
women that would that would ask the
question more like it's mothers it's
grandmothers yes and if I have children
but do not provide primary care for them
my masculinity will not be called into
question do you mean legally alimony
laws you yeah what are we talking about
we're talking about our women we talk
about question structure
these aren't questions man whatever they
are can we talk about the freaking
structure I guarantee you that if we
were to say the question structures a
byproduct of the patriarchy we could get
a very douche Deutsch to apologize yes
yeah
you're a tree are kacal question you
know what I really want to know is what
does Beecher point you to know about the
woman's experience in English yes we
show Harry he's been both yeah is that
really at least one of them it's like
that fish you know yeah I have to
retract my tirade
I'm so sorry Barry is all number
thirteen if I seek political office my
relationship with my children or who I
hired to take care of them a little bit
of a reference to number 12 will
probably not be scrutinized by the press
do you mean like president Donald
Trump's relationship with his son with
his daughter to be asked what are we
talking about here it's equal on this
one when I asked to see the person in
charge odds are I will face a person of
my own sex the higher in the
organization the person is it depends or
williams-sonoma your favorite place it's
all it's all by the way everywhere and
every you know when I go to go with my
wife where you're shopping every store
it's just men everywhere yeah that's
exactly manager all of all of the men
who were managers there named Karen as a
child I as a man wasn't my sisters look
mister been free every single one of
these questions is saying okay are there
some people in the world who are bags
and decide that they're gonna raise
better questions daughters to not be
active and outgoing and now you're going
to take that and say every single male
has that privilege because they were
told to be active not going regardless
of what the ancestors and even if their
sisters were encouraged to do that it
doesn't matter because we're just gonna
take this stereotype and just run it all
over it so I'll put you down as a maybe
yes thank you I never cheated off of any
men no only women only ap physics ap bio
I didn't cheat it oh my god I feel so
far for your classmates I guarantee they
were cheating off you
I know hey you bill you didn't write
anything are you like waiting to the end
do you like have all the answers in your
head and I was like no I'm waiting for
inspiration girl I cheated off if I'm
told the story on air before several
times I cheated off her in physical
science my entire year because I didn't
understand the teacher he had a weird
accent I didn't do very well and so I
was just cheating off her and then we
had a standardized government exam at
the end of the year we're now your
teacher was no longer in charge of your
grades and so she told me she said yep
okay I'll help you I'll let you read off
my test we're in the middle of the exam
she's set right in front of me when I
look up her shoulder and she just turns
back to I was totally wrong but I did my
weaker years going badly number 19 I
need not ask of each negative episode or
situation whether or not it has sexist
overtones I'm not doing this one because
it's written poorly the next one okay
imagine the kind of person who would
have put something like this together
every everything that happens in the
world is just another story to add into
their victim yeah hood I mean their
entire story is if there there are two
men on the cover of the New York Times
who are dead bodies where are the women
I hate to refute what you're saying but
yeah look I mean yeah
come on yeah swimming in it good guy
comic book I'm not sure the gender hold
on he looks like he does
mmm he looks like remember Turkmen Ninja
Turtles too secretive use yes he looks
like he's not yeah that's actually a
good point that you bring up Real
Housewives yeah are there any real house
husbands at home dads see throwing some
Jagermeister there are plenty of women's
only women only generous there plenty of
women only shows but anytime guys have a
guy on it this is not a Vista you cannot
be allowed into it I think that it's a
good thing for women to have women only
spaces sometimes and guys that have guy
only spaces sometimes and that being
said there is an imbalance right now or
think what can you think of that is a
male only space exclusively Country Club
Lobos you'll say like a cigar lounge a
cigar lounge I go to is really like 35
percent women surprising a man yeah but
I can't go to curbs what is there right
now yeah I think the other question is
like who cares if I'm careless with my
driving it won't be attributed to my sex
to pay way more for car insuring their
teen years right yeah yeah
teens in 20 because I'm more risk-taking
yeah that being said I have a theory
about that yes I think that men
typically in my experience are more
comfortable with what do you think all
of us have lives yes okay if you are in
the car you're both in the car neither
one of you has some kind of disability
who drives I tend to I tend to depends
on the car I Drive my car she dressers
okay I tend to more likelihood that you
will accrue an accident if you're
driving all the time and that being said
women don't get it particularly like I
do not believe for one second this
statistic that teenage girls are less
risky than boys right you know why
because we see a teenage girl and that
glow of the Android against their face
and we are going three lane
yeah it's like partner you lied number
24 even if I sleep with a lot of women
there is no chance I will be seriously
labeled a [ __ ]
nor is there any male counterpart to
slide bachelor yes it is it's called
being a boy yeah yeah well bury oh
that's that's for that's for gays no no
no it's not no no that's for both it's
why the terms there was a term CAD and
generally gonna see like a guy but oh
he's a shoe she's what I would say this
is kind of more this is indicative of a
bigger problem they say the term is
Lauder your [ __ ] we don't call guys
[ __ ] just so we don't typically I will
say man-whore in hip-hop they call men
because that's kind of the longest time
you don't call a guy a [ __ ]
but women aren't typically called ass
right yeah women aren't called pricks
it's just there are different insults
for different people just like the
racial epithets and they're all fun
they're all the colors of the rainbow
well in yourself too just want a point
that you made before for a woman to have
sex all she has to do is go out and say
yes it's not like you're high-fiving
there's no achievement right there's
nothing that you've actually done and
I'm not saying you should do it but if a
guy is trying to do that he has a much
higher chance of failure than a woman
does every worker bee was too high
fiving the queen bee after another we
went up it would just be nonstop
high-five she would have no more
handlers
yeah that's handlers I didn't know if it
was a hand or if I buy a new car chances
are I'll be offered a better price than
a woman buying the same car bsdi have do
you not have a cell phone where you shop
it and go oh here's like the best price
that I can get down the street okay I'll
give it to you what world is these guys
living in still not only that again
disco spell might lead rose and the
capital markets okay women are choosing
not to be confrontational
my wife and I went right to it it's not
far from here and I said let me do the
negotiating and she said okay and while
we were sitting there as a negotiating
technique
I ordered Hoover heats and the food came
and at one moment I said hold on and I
walked out got my Firehouse Subs walked
back in and started eating in and said
you have until I finished the sandwich
to come back to with a better offer and
she literally in front of the guy goes
just just will pay it's fine don't worry
about it and so
oh no it's that not to say no I mean I
don't care about the undercutting part
but we're cutting you you must have
given air old did you can't beat my wife
okay in there give her a shot I gave her
a sandwich too okay so the point was is
that for whatever reason she didn't feel
comfortable to push back and like get a
better deal and I felt more than
comfortable doing that or playing a game
of negotiate a car now that's not to say
that maybe during the course of growing
up that there weren't people who
discourage her from doing that whether
it was a man or a woman though I don't
know right as I see a lot of women to
scourge and other women from being
forward or being my wife is fantastic so
I to refer to my left hook as a sandwich
cotton more free coffees yeah and I can
you should be like oh yeah I get that
from Starbucks they didn't try go what
you didn't pay you gave her a ten she
back with a ten back when I used to have
cash you know this was like no Reagan
was president that's not common because
what it's not common know it's stuck
it's a place excels offi they generally
charge you for the coffee don't sell you
that coffee they're not doing anything
is it well why would he do that because
he wants to have sex with you
I'm not conventionally attractive the
disadvantages are relatively small and
easy to ignore I've never called that my
disadvantage before but I don't think if
it's like if it's Kate Bosworth and
Clint Howard you're going to skew the
bell curve yeah very writing this
question crying on to the notepad he
looks like riggan sorry he looks like
where the wild things are
the guy weren't allowed to sleep in the
big pile shaped one of the guys down a
little bit yeah I hate it I hate it for
this guy but a bill saying he did it to
himself
33 my ability to make important
decisions and my capability in general
will never be questions depending on
what time of the month it is well listen
that's just because we need to know when
to cut a wide swath yeah that's super
safety that's out of concern for you as
much as ourselves it's also one that by
the way is used both such I don't think
I don't think that men in the workplace
are like it's that time of the month
I've never had that happen but I have
had women doing I'm sorry when they've
treated someone really poorly I'm sorry
I'm on my period in worse like oh sorry
yeah that happens doesn't have an oh
yeah I've only heard a reference by
women yeah by the way did you know that
women don't have to go through that my
way areas yes you can you can take birth
control your entire life yeah
so you can stop you know I don't even
want to get into this next one
every major religion in the world is led
primarily by people of my own sex even
God in most major religions is pictured
as male and let me go ultimate
patriarchy God is mmm I love this one I
love this one hey I just want you to be
very clear everyone out there looking
right in the camera if you are religious
you're a sexist yes that's that's the
end that's the end stroke that's the end
of the question if I have a wife or a
live-in girlfriend chances are we'll
divide up household chores so that she
does most of the labor the most
repetitive and unrewarding mean it means
that you give your wife this [ __ ] work
to do yeah now a lot of times a lot of
relationships the wife may take on more
of those responsibilities because she
likes it better than to be doing the
bulk of housework or spa and I don't
know if you know this but women's burden
of household chores have gone down
significantly since the 50s as well as
their personal happiness not saying that
there's necessarily a causation there
but I'm saying this idea that women not
having to do household chores to
suddenly free them and allow them to be
happier that's not true didn't really
let's see how you all like taking out
the trash 31 assuming I am heterosexual
Mac zooming billboards television movies
pornography and virtually all of media's
filled with images of scantily clad
women intended to appeal to me sexually
such images of men exist but are rare I
love how he loaded back into the
question I likes like by the way they do
exist there Eric says some Street Fair
he said assuming heterosexual ha ha why
do we do that prison I know he wants the
answer and he's going to get some answer
that he wants I do I do think that the
underlying requests here of this of this
question is that there are more pictures
of scantily clad men very like isn't
that is that what Barry's asking for I
think so with men like you see men like
Gucci Armani a shirtless that being said
there are no sexual glands organs or
signals there and others when we talk
about violet what we talk about sort of
the bio evolutionary mechanisms right
when a man looks at a woman who's in a
bikini what does he see he sees breasts
those feed young those feed babies those
are important he sees birthing hips
right the one thing that would a man are
inconsequential they are basically a
mistake just whether they're from one
direction has three of them but they
look at unless we have put it this way
the equivalent would be you know you see
in all those sports is it sport
illustrate where they do the body paint
that looks like a swimsuit yeah imagine
if I just walked around and I painted my
my balls like a bumblebee bumblebee Suns
are gone under sock and so wait those
are any testicles painting like a
bumblebee yeah
nobody rushing out to get that magazine
in general I am under much less pressure
to be thin than my female counterparts
are if I am fat I probably suffer fewer
social and economic consequences for
being thick can we bring back which both
in X to this is the first question in
these like and
yeah you know sexual harassment on the
street virtually never happens to me I
do not need to plot my movements through
public space in order to avoid being
sexually harassed or to mitigate sexual
harassment no but a panda can wish I
think that women are obviously more
likely to be sexually harassed now we
need a differentiate between even when
the women put these videos online that
said I was catcalled and some of the men
were saying you're the most beautiful
woman I've ever seen
I don't think sexual harassment right
mates mind every unwanted advancement is
sexual harassment then there we would
have no couples right because that
sooner or later I managed to take a risk
saying you have a beautiful smile or I
love the way you're here look sir wow
you're beautiful now someone said hey
come on over here of course that's
completely outside of the realm of
propriety that being said most men want
to kick those men's asses yes we're not
fans of anyway
number 47 the last one curb stop I have
married I have the privilege of being
unaware of the can we bring this up
bring it up unaware of my male privilege
yes I gotta ask what kind of selfish
chauvinist writes an article like this
yeah I can just see him sitting on his
bed weeping yeah because of all his mail
program yeah but you wouldn't know where
his weird anamorphic amoebic body and
then the tears begin right it would all
just in a pool of ooze and pudding
here's one thing I'm gonna say okay um
men are weak this isn't that I think is
important okay we can talk about
patriarchy but I want to leave on this
note and this is what's so toxic with
this is that it presumes that men are
looking to take advantage of exploit or
that or you know what over all that we
hate women I will tell you this this is
a point that you brought up earlier you
know about women mistreating other women
yeah I start about my wife who was a
called women like oh that's she's such a
shrew someone who's who's mean and
gossipy and Cadi men as a general now
there are exceptions guys who beat their
wives of course just like there are
exceptions of women who have crack
babies right who don't take care of
their children
that being said men typically speaking
every man
this room is looking to love women right
they're looking to enjoy the company of
women that's why we work so hard at
trying to find a woman that's why we're
willing to take the risk of facing
public embarrassment by going to speak
to a strange woman and women don't
typically do that with them because we
desire women at a very deep and I mean
spiritual emotional physical level that
being said women often are looking to
compete with other women men tend to
treat women better than a lot of women
treat women just as women not feminists
women tend to treat men better than most
men treat other men I think there's this
ill-conceived notion that men all of a
sudden we get behind closed doors
without women and we're just everything
is hunky-dory we're nice with each other
we're plotting and how we can take
advantage of women when the truth is
most men go into the workforce right
they go to their place of work it is an
absolute pride-swallowing seeds they
work with guys they don't like you're
constantly being knocked around people
are giving each other a hard time and
they want to come home into the warm
embrace and the solace of their wife
because that is their favorite person if
you walk around in this world thinking
that men hate women or are looking to
take advantage of women you are going to
miss out on some of the greatest joys in
life namely the differences between men
and women and why we desire each other
to complete one another it's a beautiful
thing and instead you've turned it into
a pile of your face
Perry Deutsch you've turned it into
something as ugly as you shame on you
but you are still cordially invited onto
this show now your screens not frozen
this is one of those this is one of
those moving pictures
takis see that okay there's a video
playing somewhere in a box subscribe hit
the notification bell if you are
subscribed because subscriptions don't
mean a whole lot but we really do love
having you on this channel and I hope
you enjoyed this Bernie video because I
know he didn't and I can you know I can
still live with myself it didn't freeze
that's still me okay click one of the
things